[Music]
democrats caught breaking coveted rules
as the fight over vaccine mandates
reaches a critical point president biden
defined a city-wide mandate in d.c after
he and the first lady were spotted
maskless at a ritzy restaurant while
secret service members were covered up
the white house excusing the behavior
this way
there is a mask requirement inside dc
restaurants yet president biden the
first lady were not wearing masks while
walking around a dc restaurant on
saturday why
well i think what we were referring to
is a photo of them walking out of a
restaurant after they they had eaten
masked in hand where they had not yet
put them back on yet so i would say of
course
there are moments when we all don't put
mass back on as quickly as we should but
i don't think we should lose lose a
force through the trees here president
biden not alone chicago mayor lori
lightfoot being accused of covet
hypocrisy after posing maskless for a
photo at a basketball game mayor
lightfoot is locked in a very bitter
standoff with police over vaccine
mandates up to half of the city's 13 000
officers could reportedly be fired if
they don't get the shot today is also
the deadline for seattle police officers
to submit their vaccination status
here's one police officer let's go to
this call for right away
a washington trooper signing out for the
last time let's listen here
i'd like to thank the
citizens of yakima county as well as my
fellow officers within the valley
without you guys i would have been very
successful and you've kept me safe and
got me home my family every night
um
thank you for that
um
wish i could say more but um this is it
so
state 10 34 this is the last time you'll
hear me in a state patrol car
and jay and zeke can kiss me
and so he has now left the building and
the police force jesse did any of these
politicians think about attrition i mean
that's obviously what's going to happen
when you slap these vast mandates on
these people
right now in seattle they're going to
lose what 140 officers in the middle of
a crime wave historic we've already seen
retirements there and they're going into
what's called phase four mobilization
dana and they only use this during riots
it's when every single sworn officer has
to come in seven days a week
12 hour shifts and cover each other's
butt i just don't know how they're going
to do that after they've had what i
think they just shattered a three-decade
murder number last year they're already
on pace to top that and in kings county
80 percent of the drive-bys are black
americans so jenny dirk and the mayor
black lives matter don't they you're
gonna keep police off the streets in
that type of environment but i have to
talk about joe biden's dinner dana
hunter biden must have picked up the tab
on this thing because this restaurant is
even too pricey for gutfeld they have a
caviar tasting for 250.
then they have something i've never even
heard before the new zealand scorpion
fish
for
275 dollars a dover soul for 115 i've
never seen it over 110.
and then the guy must have had a lot of
cocktails last night because he didn't
even show up to work today joe biden had
no public events on his schedule today i
hope it was worth it this is why this
guy is so discombobulated he walks
indoors through a dc restaurant with no
mask but does a zoom call by himself in
the white house with a full mask on
that's why this country's so confused
about kovac because he's confused and
then in washington dc why do they even
have a mass mandate seven day death
average in d.c is zero
it is zero why doesn't the mayor put on
a a bullet proof vest mandate
more people are dying from bullets than
coveted 19. you live in washington dc i
do need a mass mandate there listen i
will say that we've done a really good
job of getting a good majority of our
city vaccinated so bravo to mario bowser
for that uh listen and i i get it i
think the truth of the matter is that
these mass mandates can be annoying
sometimes they're misleading because one
city has them and the neighboring city
does not have them but when you have
elected leaders who are supposed to lead
the people not wearing a mask it's
really hard to then tell john q public
you need to have your mask on when the
elected office what about mayor and lori
lightfoot on that well listen i have not
the first time i i have a lot of
problems with mayor lori lightfoot
especially how she happens to be running
the chicago public school system
and how she's not testing the students
there but it's worth pointing out that
what's happening the police department
like all the other city employees have
been for have been have been asked to
take the vaccine right the educators in
chicago educators in chicago 90 of them
are vaccinated um and they've turned in
their backs they're seen cards no
problem city employees the same she's
also allowed said if you don't want to
get the vaccine if you do not want to
turn the vaccine card you can test twice
a week so if you test twice a week you
don't have to turn in a vaccination card
what i can't fathom here is this this is
about making sure that we keep police
officers safe and keep them working um
and when we know when officer down
reported that the number one cause of
death for police officers in 2021 and
2020 has been covered 19 why would you
not want to keep your police officers
safe which is the battle that she seems
to be having with the headquarters
listen to mayor lori lightfoot this is
what she said about police unions and
insurrection
police unions are not authorized to
strike it's in a collective bargaining
agreement it's a matter of state law
what we've seen from
the fraternal order of police in
particular leadership is a lot of
misinformation a lot of half-truths and
frankly flat out lies in order to induce
an insurrection and i imagine some of
those officers who decide that that
don't want to be vaccinated or
frustrated that she goes to the
basketball game and she doesn't have to
wear a mask she gets to live her life
with armed security while she tried to
defund the police last year she gets to
do that and now she's lecturing and and
telling these police officers
essentially they're domestic terrorists
who are trying to
rise and you know create an insurrection
because they happen to have a union
that's standing up for their right of
choice about whether they want to be
vaccinated or not for whatever reason
natural immunity maybe they have some
other condition maybe they just don't
want the vaccine um but when you look at
the way that politicians in general like
lori lightfoot have handled this and joe
biden in particular you know it can seem
like oh well it's just a mask that he
didn't have when he walked out but when
you look at the videos of toddlers on
airplanes getting kicked off with their
parents and screaming when you look at
kids sitting in school all day who are
little who have to wear that mask for
eight hours it is infuriating to watch
the president of the united states do
this and then the press secretary
justify and say well we don't really
need to to focus on that there are
consequences for this in dc there's a
thousand dollar fine if you don't comply
and if you're on amtrak and you don't
have your mask on they can kick you off
the train and so you know they can laugh
about it and i would argue that nobody
should be wearing masks given the
vaccination right and the natural
immunity but if you're going to force
other people to do it you're going to
throw kids off airplanes with their
parents and they're just trying to go
see their families then he should be
leading and you know take it away from
everyone if that's the case greg for a
brief moment this morning i thought well
maybe with this hypocrisy on the mask
maybe they'll just decide that we can
let it go and let it be people's choice
if they want to wear a mask or not but
apparently that's not happening no
you've got to separate the power from
the powerless and the mask does that
wonderfully and why should laurie
lightfoot have to wear a mask and hide
that beautiful smile because you know
she has so much to smile about and to
hide it in my opinion it's a crime i
think what you're talking when you're
talking about the kids and everything
like that we're uh we're now uh in the
uh tyranny of safety phase where um i
had to go get a medical procedure on
friday an endoscopy
they it was required that the person
driving me there and the person picking
me up had to be either
mandated a shot or a negative coven even
if they didn't enter the building that's
insane all right but this isn't about
the practical benefits of masking it's
about how the jackasses that relish
reprimanding us do not follow their own
protocols that's why they got into
politics so they can create the laws
that they are immune from we hate line
cut cutters that's in our blood our
genetics and people who scoff at laws
that we follow but when the line cutters
are the people who control the line
that's war i mean that's the letter meat
cake phase of this is when somebody is
actually telling you the rules and
violating them in front of you on a
smaller scale it's like political
politicians who start wars
but their kids are immune from the draft
yeah it's like we create and enforce the
laws that we are uh that we then mock uh
and we see this and it's from like look
from ted kennedy and chappaquiddick to
hunter biden with his guns and his crack
political power is that safety net that
keeps you from being arrested or being
in trouble especially if you're a
democrat how was your procedure how did
it it went smooth yeah
they went to little camera down there
they did find your class ring dana oh
yeah i apologize i mean it's small and
the diamonds will be coming out later
okay great if you could just pick those
out for me hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else